hey guys this is s the founder of thing
Kara and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and we
just got back from comic-con and
obviously the biggest news of this comic
con is WB's announcement of the Batman
vs super as for Man of Steel to that's
what it's going to be instead of just a
Superman's right and we haven't to do
hasn't confirmed yet what the title is
going to be I mean the speculation at
first was maybe Batman vs Superman but I
think a lot of people think Christopher
Nolan's kind of even though he's behind
the produce in production now so he's
kind of subtle you know with his title
so maybe my just be Batman and Superman
won't be like Batman vs Superman kinda
like Freddy vs. Jason that kind of
little corny I don't know it at the same
time though is a business move I think
it's a good idea cuz that's right there
Batman vs Superman the casual thing I
will know exactly what it is when you
start getting into the whole like you
know man of steel Dark Knight it so much
yeah so so what did you think of the
news I mean it's a pretty big news it's
big news I think I wonder if Cavill knew
about because he kept dude were
interviewing him wild man of steel was
his roommate of premier asking like we
think about a justice league movie he's
like even if it he's like I don't think
we're there yet then some I said what
about a batman superman movie he's like
you know what that would be a good idea
so maybe he was hearing buzz about it I
think Justice League is gonna be hard DC
it's a little bit too late to follow
Marvel's plan they're not going to
introduce a character one here one there
but his batman vs superman movie might
allow people to kind of just ease their
way in i'm gonna get something later
here that might link to some other DC
characters that could come out of this
storyline potential potential story for
our parents are meant to but i think one
thing we had to talk about what made me
think of this was who's gonna play
batman well the thing that was thinking
that was like that yeah that's kind of
the big thing look next yeah because
after Christian Bale in in Nolan's
universe you know and I know like lots
and lots of people think that Christian
Bale's gonna come down he said he's done
he has stated he's done yeah not only is
he done he said he's done playing any
type of like superhero comic book type
of
a role so yeah that's not gonna happen
um hootie-hoo do you want who do you
think it would be a good person copy on
my list what a lot of you been talking
about to and i think i agree with would
be maybe I like Luke Evans British guy
who's in immortals he's just recently in
uh fashion furious 6 as the villain I
think he's good he's he's not like we
would call classically handsome you like
the best but I liked his Christian Bale
Isabel's kind of I mean he's got a
little rugged this is good yeah bezel
rugged-looking I like Batman a little
rugged I like that about Luke Evans I
love Ryan Gosling as an actor I don't
know how good of a Batman he would be
money to bulk up a little bit he could
do that and he's he's a he's got range
but he'd i don't i don't really Bruce I
don't know he's a really good actor I
think the problem is his voice I mean
yeah this is kind of high right voice I
don't know I I mean obviously when he's
Batman he can disguise it but even as
Bruce it just seems a little bit odd to
me the kind of fe segue into indy year
pics i know you and i both were thinking
maybe Carly urban yeah carbon I think
would be great we saw him in dread you
know and Star Trek is our track hehe I
think he'd be a great Bruce Wayne in
Batman you know he kind of has a
grittier look yeah and he could he I
think that could work i don't know even
if you guys Cena when it he was in red
yeah he was in red and he was also in
born what was the second bourne movie oh
yeah he was in a bourne supremacy yeah
for supremacy he was the hit man yeah
she's a little bit of russian yay like
this evil right the bama is not evil we
definitely has a darkened a dark yeah um
one of my pics too is I think guy pearce
would be great he's yeah he is a good
idea Rudy he was supposed to be in the
original one right Ram I think maybe
when aronofsky was supposed to direct it
yeah I think he's a phenomenal actor I
think he I think he can pull off the
Bruce Wayne in my in the Batman I don't
know how old he is now yeah I think
that's other thing blood were suggesting
Jon Hamm I think jon Hamm's are great i
got the dark hair got the dark look a
little bit but I think he's not old but
I think in the 40s is like a comment
maybe thinking more guy was in his 30s
kind of like you know Henry Cavill is
late 20s early 30s maybe mid 30
but yeah I think with Guy Pearce and Jon
Hamm maybe the age i don't know that old
the thing with jon hamm knows he kind of
fits more Clark kent/superman and we are
going all right that's true yeah clean
cut yeah I definitely Bruce Wayne he's
got John I don't know about Batman but
right Bruce Wayne I think he's got it
right you know right I think some people
want to see older Batman because a lot
of you have been thinking that this
movie might be linked to Frank Miller's
Dark Knight Returns and maybe they did
Christian Bale they could do that story
but with a younger one I don't I don't
know if they're gonna do it I have
another idea with that because that
story is when they're both older
Superman's older in that story Batman's
much older than that story I think
they're gonna try to start young they
are because of you know Henry Campbell's
young and so I reckon I've like to all
right you know and also then they want
to continue on to justice league in a
more Batman movies they don't want to
recast I mean the reason why everyone
thinks of you know dark net returns is
because they had Henry linux come out
throughout the the panel and zack snyder
brought him out and he read the quote
from ya fri darn a writer write you know
about Batman beating Superman Frank
Miller that's supposed to be like
Christian sorry who's Bernal got most of
his stuff for Dark Knight from Frank
influence from Frank Miller Miller I
mean we're like the long halloween right
Jeff oh yeah yeah so yeah I was gonna
say this is my this little bit of you
know I have my hypothesis here my little
Theory going on here so there's supposed
to be as easter egg possibly no one's
confirmas and Man of Steel where when
Superman Clark as he was walking through
the this old ship that ship it's like
how many thousands of years old and they
see the empty cryotube rumor is maybe
that could be Supergirl yes now there is
a Supergirl storyline and one of the
first two volumes of the superman batman
series from DC Comics a few years back
Michael turned to the are jeph loeb did
the story for that and maybe maybe do a
batman superman Supergirl storyline
which would be cool like they don't and
then in that storyline wonder woman
shows up now I'm just going kind of
geeky fanboy here going off but i'm
thinking maybe they could just introduce
not do maybe justice league but
introduce a few more suppose to get the
trinity at least get Wonder Woman
on-screen Eve it's a cameo yeah on there
i'm thinking more like in her not Wonder
Woman now right yeah I mean kind of like
I think they should introduce Lex Luthor
all right into the movie but not he's
not gonna be the villain he'll just be
introduced right um because the way I
think they're gonna set it up is that
that Batman is kind of not the villain
but he's kind of the antagonist that's a
Superman in this movie and then I'm sure
at the end I'll be buddies who's gonna
be in to see because Superman and I know
I know you and I didn't have a problem
with it some Superman Oh Pierce had an
issue with how dark he was in manage so
he was maybe darken and we've seen him
of course there are tons of dark stories
where she bends dark and comic books
like he kills few he has killed before
so I wonder like how dogs are gonna make
Bruce 10 because this man of steel is
hopeful but he's still darker than most
supermen so like how dark is Batman
gonna be I'm curious to see like who
this Batman is gonna be like it depends
they made a more action right a hero
round something I do yeah like a more
darker buddy type of guy who knows but I
mean I'm excited for I I thought that
they should have done a Batman movie
first just to get people comfortable
with whoever the new Batman in before
they did either Batman vs Superman or
justice league movie that was my
personal opinion but this is still good
this you know that means that you know
WB is happy they're obviously waiting to
see the returns on man of steel yeah
since the box office why's it did
phenomenal all right they decided to put
the go ahead cuz I I know mana steel did
not do well trust me would I be hearing
about no no Batman Superman that me a
little too out there but I I'm a lonely
am a little hesitant about a little bit
worried is it Gore now Snyder is gonna
be co-writing the story out the
screenplay but the co-writing the story
and last time I seen something that
Snyder wrote you know that was a sucker
punch that was a little worth what I've
ever seen so visually beautiful you know
Snyder's got the visuals down visually
beautiful there's no substance of that
story so I'm hoping that no one is there
guiding I hope you know got going knows
how to he knows how to you know tell
beginning middle that I hope they can I
hope they slow down this time was that
something i have on here's what can
snyder and gore do maybe a little
differently i was just a hope that they
can slow the story down and not try to
rush and just go go go go
like burrito the story breathe a little
yeah man steel is definitely like just
punch punch punch yeah there's no
breathing room no no that was one of my
biggest compress as well like they
didn't let things breathe especially
that the past stuff you know right um
but yeah I think it's good news and I'm
excited it was a 2015 that's not that
far what that no two years wait we can
wait till two years summer now yeah all
right any fifteens are gonna be a crazy
crazy yeah that's gonna be crazy what is
it like that's Avengers 2 major see Star
Wars Episode 7 Wow and now Superman vs
them that's gonna be a huge summer I
think there's a bunch of other stuff
yeah that's gonna be a huge summer I'm
excited I'm getting bombed alright guys
so let's know what you thought of the
news of Batman vs Superman and also who
you think should play Batman any of the
actors that we said or other ones you
can post your comments below on the
website and on this YouTube video make
sure you subscribe to our channel that's
think you're a pro and you can also
follow us on twitter minds at the kira
and i'm at griffin de and we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans